- [Interviewer] So Tina,
where are you from?
- I'm originally from Portland, Oregon.
- [Interviewer] Portland, how
long have you been down here?
- Since '97.
- [Interviewer] You've
been on skid row since '97.
- No I've been in Los Angeles since '97.
- [Interviewer] Oh and how'd
you end up on skid row?
- I was married to a guy that,
the marriage didn't go
to well between us two.
- [Interviewer] That'll happen.
It'll happen.
And you're sleeping where?
- I started in Los Angeles.
The old side of the old women's center.
- [Interviewer] The what women's center?
- The old side of the old
downtown women's center.
- [Interviewer] And that's
a nice place to sleep?
- Yep I have my own apartment.
I have my own refrigerator,
but we share, I have to share,
we have a community bathroom
and a community kitchen.
- [Interviewer] Yeah but it's
a nice warm place to sleep.
- Oh yeah.
- [Interviewer] Beats the street.
Have you been on the streets as well?
- Before I moved in here.
- [Interviewer] Yeah that's rough.
I've been down here.
Some nights where it's so cold
and people are just laying
on the sidewalk all night.
It's like, oh, and then
when it rains or whatever,
it's like, it's just so rough.
- I know.
- [Interviewer] What's the
craziest thing you've seen
down here in skid row?
I've seen crazy stuff, but
you're living down here.
So you've seen it.
- I've seen it all.
- [Interviewer] Tell me a story or two.
- I've seen women,
let me see,
I've seen women run down the street naked.
God, totally crazy.
- [Interviewer] I saw a woman one morning,
sun was just coming up,
I saw a woman taking a crap in the middle
of a big crowded sidewalk.
It's just like, she
just dropped her pants.
Took a dump right there on the sidewalk.
Right in the broad daylight.
It was crazy.
I haven't seen that before.
So your nose, what happened to your nose?
- I got hit with a pipe wrench.
- [Interviewer] You got
hit with a pipe wrench?
That was here on skid row?
Yeah it's a rough neighborhood, isn't it?
Yeah that'll wreck your day, right?
- [Tina] Yeah it did.
- [Interviewer] And you
never got it straightened out
or anything?
You just left it be.
Isn't there a place somewhere down here
you can get that taken care?
- I'm not, I'm not going
to get it taken care of.
- [Interviewer] I like your pants.
- [Tina] Oh thanks.
- [Interviewer] Let me see your shoes too.
Look at those things, very fun.
So do you have family?
Do you have kids?
Do you have anything like?
- I've got a 21 year old
daughter, three grandkids.
My dad got remarried
after my mom passed away
and I've got two older
sisters, one younger brother.
My stepsister and two stepbrothers.
Nieces and nephews like crazy.
- [Interviewer] Yeah
they're all in Portland?
- [Tina] All up in Oregon, yup.
- [Interviewer] And do
they know you're down here?
- [Tina] Yup.
- [Interviewer] Do you,
do you talk to them?
- [Tina] Oh yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
So you're doing drugs at all
or no, you seem really clean.
- [Tina] No.
- [Interviewer] You seem clean.
- [Tina] Yeah I've always,
I've been clean for years.
- [Interviewer] You just can't get it,
you just can't get money
together to get a job or do--
- [Tina] No, no, I'm
on, I'm on disability.
- [Interviewer] For what?
- [Tina] My seizures.
- [Interviewer] Oh, you have seizures?
- [Tina] Yeah I use to, I don't have,
I haven't had them in years.
- [Interviewer] Like grand mal seizures?
Yeah, oof.
And those are brought out just by what?
- [Tina] Just everything,
stress, there's different things.
- [Interviewer] Oh man.
Yeah that'll that'll slow you down,
but what, what,
what are your dreams?
What would you love to see happen
in the next five years in your life?
Where would you like to be?
- Married again.
- [Interviewer] Do you
talk to your daughter?
- Oh yeah I talk to her a lot.
- [Interviewer] She's got a
family, or she's working or--
- She's in school right now.
She's got one more year of college.
- [Interviewer] That's good,
where's she going to school?
- Portland State University.
- [Interviewer] Oh excellent.
Well can I give you a little something to
make your day a little easier?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
So are you making money
here on the street?
- Not as much as I used to
- [Interviewer] But there
there'll be guys that pick you up.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And how
often does that go on?
- Every night.
- [Interviewer] Every night.
So what hours is that going on?
- All depends how my night goes.
I'm in culinary school right now.
So I know I only out, I come
out here once in a while.
- [Interviewer] Oh really?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You're
going to culinary school?
Good for you.
And do you do business with these guys?
You do it in their car or
they take you somewhere--
- No, hotel, cars,
- [Interviewer] Wherever?
And how much money will you make?
- On a really good
night, over 200 dollars,
on a really good night.
- [Interviewer] Really, that's good.
- Of course my dude's in jail.
- [Interviewer] Who's that?
- His name is Casey.
He's in jail.
They busted him for sales.
He didn't wasn't selling anything.
What it was, they pulled
up on his homeboy,
and his homeboys girl.
Well they pulled him out
the indication with him
and three females snitched on him.
So he's in jail.
He was suppose to get out in
January but a riot broke out.
So he won't be getting out
until October of this year.
- [Interviewer] Where can I drop you off?
I'm going to take you somewhere.
- Seventh and Town on the
other side of the light.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
You going to go around the block here?
- I got shot.
- [Interviewer] You got shot?
- Yeah down Agatha and Crocker.
Three times, I got two bullets in my back,
they told me, we moved
the one out of my arm.
- [Interviewer] And you still
have bullets in your body?
- In my back,
they can't pull them out because
they'll leave me paralyzed.
I'm a survivor.
I've survived down here for years.
- [Interviewer] Yes I've
been seeing you down here
for about five, six years,
you actually, you look a little cleaner,
and better now than I saw you last time.
I think when I photographed
you the first time it was a
you didn't look so good.
Well, good luck to you.
- Oh yeah.
- [Interviewer] You seem to be
doing in the right direction
at least.